de parler de cette affaire avec curro
chain ou avocat franco iranien bonsoir
monsieur merci d'être avec nous cette
autorisation une formation a donné par
l'administration obama en 2014 puis qui
continue sous le mandat de trump parce
que clairement c'est une faute
gouvernementale de la voir accorder
bonsoir merci de m'avoir invité
je sais pas si c'est une faute
gouvernementales ou pas mais ce qu'on
peut savoir
on peut être sûr c'est que depuis depuis
des 31 depuis une vingtaine d'années au
moins une trentaine d'années c'est que
les saoudiens bénéficient d'une
formation aux états unis les les
militaires à messaoud ya tout ce qui est
de la police saoudienne peuvent aller
aux états unis pénale aux etats-unis et
bénéficier d'une formation la france au
fait la même chose aussi les policiers
français forment des policiers étrangers
les gendarmes français forment des
gendarmes étrangers pour une fois je
vais défendre les américains c'est que
c'est pas parce que des militaires ou
des paramilitaires saoudiens ont été
formés aux états unis que c'est une
faute américaine
ils vont aux états unis sais pas s'il ya
des intérêts économiques énormes
gigantesque entre les états unis et
l'arabie saoudite et l'arabie saoudite
en fait
idea deux pays qui bénéficient d'un pass
3 total aux états unis c'est l'arabie
saoudite et l'israël l'arabie saoudite
achète des équipements militaires des
sommes astronomiques aux états unis et
ils peuvent bénéficier d'un passe-droit
s'agissant tout ce qui peut faire aux
états unis je peux revenir tout à
l'heure si vous vous posez si vous vous
posez des questions sur les attentats du
11 septembre justement qui ont été
commis par des par des saoudiens
effectivement on s'en souvient je vous
invite à y revenir
tout à l'heure mais la question qu'on
peut se poser quand même si les états
unis ne
ne craint-il pas justement que ces
formations puissent être utilisés à des
fins on va dire pas vraiment approprié
comme ça semble t-il été le cas dans
cette affaire cachot vie on sait aussi
que l'arabie saoudite est impliqué au
yémen c'est l'une des pires crises
humanitaires que a priori les deux pays
partagent pas vraiment les mêmes valeurs
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est ce sont
les états unis qui sont toujours
promptes à la voilà à remettre en avant
leurs valeurs morales voilà on peut
peut-être s'étonner quand même bon on
peut s'étonner mais il faut pas
s'étonner c'est parce que les saoudiens
achètent
je sais pas si vous venez d'un entretien
télévisé où il y avait le président
donald trump et mbs le prince hériter
qui était aux états unis et le président
entrant elle montré que les l'arabie
saoudite allait acheter pour 100
milliards de dollars d'équipements
militaires à eux donc face à cette somme
gigantesque les américains ne vont pas
s'étonner ou ne vont pas s'indigner
devant quelques quelques mâles fait que
les saoudiens vont commettre des
saoudiens comme vous avez des oreillers
mène comme est [ __ ] des moeurs des
assassinats la même chose aux états unis
comme ils l'ont fait pendant le 11
septembre les américains sont attachés
points et mains liées par les saoudiens
par l'argent des saoudiens et mbs
profitent de cet argent pour pouvoir
j'allais bien muselé les américains
c'est courant que des agents étrangers
reçoivent ainsi des déformations
militaires sur le sol de ses alliés
c'est une pratique commune finalement
c'est une pratique très content comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure il y à des
policiers des militaires étrangers qui
suivent les mêmes formations en france
vous savez que la france est un pays
spécialisé dans tout ce qui est lutte
antiterroriste surtout urbaine il y à
des policiers des gendarmes étrangers
qui viennent suivre des formations ici
en france et c'est la même chose qui se
passe aux etats unis
enfin s'ils sont compétents dans ces
domaines là et on peut pas savoir
davance une fois que l'arabie saoudite
ou d'autres pays étrangers on voit des
militaires ou des paramilitaires aux
états unis qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
après
dans ce cas là c'était des commandos qui
allaient assassiner des qui a les
assassinats journaliste aoudia à
istanbul et qui l'ont découpé en
morceaux mais les américains ne
pouvaient pas savoir d'avancé
et s'il allait faire ça ou pas c'est
c'est impossible de savoir donc on peut
pas reprocher à un pays de former des
militaires ou des policiers et par
avance parce qu'ils vont peut-être
commettre des actes terroristes
après c'est impossible de savoir et
comme je vous ai dit les américains dans
ce cas là il pouvait pas savoir mais
juste pour revenir sur le cas durant
sept ans vous savez que le l'attentât
durant sept ans a été commis la majorité
du commando étaient américains saoudiens
et les saoudiens n'ont pas été
poursuivis devant la justice américaine
et même l'ambassadeur de l'arabie
saoudite aux états unis a été reçue et
quelques jours après par le président
bush en lui présentant peut-être ses
excuses ou autre chose mais les cerveaux
diane bénéficie d'un passe-droit total
aux états unis aux etats unis parce que
ailleurs c'est peut-être que compliquer
un certain pays comme notamment
l'allemagne un des pays européens ont
stoppé leurs ventes d'armes à l'arabie
saoudite en pleine guerre du yémen qui
tuent de nombreux civils
les américains même ne commence pas être
un petit peu embarrassé par cette alliée
un petit peu gênant notamment en termes
de droits de l'homme j'allais vous dire
oui devrait être embarrassé mais les
américains sont plutôt ce qu'il en reste
qui intéresse les algériens en premier
c'est l'argent et c'est la vente de leur
équipement militaire et il devrait
normalement gênés par ce parce prince
héritier qui commet des assassinats qui
fait des attentats et qui enclenche des
guerres un peu partout mais
malheureusement ils achètent énormément
d'armement aux américains est aussi bien
aux français et ils arrivent à s'en
passer
on sait que c'est lui qui a ordonné à
peu près on est à peu près sûr que c'est
lui qui a ordonné le meurtre de cash au
guide et vous avez vu qu'en france on
entendre pas parler aux états unis on
n'entend pas parler et qu' il est même
invité au sommet g20 à peu partout dans
le monde même si on sait que c'est lui
qui commettent ces attentats là alors
que si ça retarde notre pays je vous
dire parce que je suis d'origine et
rennes
si c'était si ça aurait était l'iran on
les aurait banni du monde occidental du
sommet g20 est un peu partout et même
des médias merci beaucoup gauche
coureurs chelou d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france